JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about line integrals
of vector fields.
And I have one problem
here that requires
you to do two line integrals of
vector fields on that subject.
So OK.
So in both problems, F is going
to be the vector field whose
coordinates are x*y and
x squared plus y squared.
And C is going to be the
arc of the parabola y
equals x squared that
starts at the point (1, 1)
and ends at the point (2, 4).
All right?
So what I'd like you to do
is to compute the integral
over this curve C of F dot
dr in two different ways.
So the first time,
I'd like you to use
the natural parametrization x
equals t, y equals t squared.
For me, at least, that's
the first parametrization
that I think of when I
think about this curve.
But I'd also like you
to do it again using
a different
parametrization, using
the parametrization x equals e
to the t, y equals e to the 2t.
So this still parametrizes
the curve y equals x squared,
since e to the t squared
equals e to the 2t.
So why don't you pause the
video, have a go at computing
this integral using these two
different parametrizations,
come back, and we can
work it out together.
So let's get started.
We want to compute a line
integral of a vector field F.
So we know that the integral
over our curve C of F
dot dr-- well,
usually we write--
F equals M, N. The two
components are M and N. So
in this case, this is going to
be equal to the integral over C
of M dx plus N dy.
Now, in our case,
we know what F is.
We know that F is
the vector field x*y,
x squared plus y squared.
So this is equal to the integral
over C of x*y dx plus x squared
plus y squared dy.
And now we just need to plug
in in our two different cases,
into our parametrizations, and
this will turn into an integral
that we can evaluate.
So let's have a look-see.
So in our first
parametrization over here,
we have x equals t and
y equals t squared.
And we want this parametrization
to go from the points (1, 1)
to the point (2, 4).
So that means that t-- x--
t is going from 1 to 2.
OK.
So I'm going to just write
equals, and continue on.
So in this first part--
so t is our parameter,
and it's going from 1 to 2.
So x*t is going to be t times
t squared, and dx is dt.
And then plus-- so x
squared plus y squared is
t squared plus t to the fourth.
And dy is times 2t dt,
since y is t squared.
All right.
So this is our integral.
And now it's
straightforward to compute.
This is a single variable
integral of a polynomial,
so we might have some fraction
arithmetic in our future,
but nothing horrible.
So let's collect our dt's.
So this is the
integral from 1 to 2.
So here I've got 2 t cubed
plus 2 t to the fifth.
And here I have t cubed.
So that's 3 t cubed plus
2 t to the fifth dt.
OK, and so now we
have to evaluate.
So this is equal to--
let me just continue it.
So 3 t cubed becomes 3
t to the fourth over 4.
Plus 2 t to the
fifth becomes-- well,
t to the sixth over 6--
2 t to the sixth over 6,
so that's plus t to the
sixth over 3, between t
equals 1 and 2.
And let me just bring
that computation up here.
So that's equal to 3 times
16 over 4, plus 64 over 3,
minus 3/4 plus 1/3.
OK, and now we
gotta work this out.
So this is maybe 12, and
the thirds give me 21,
so that's 33 minus 3/4.
So that's 32 and 1/4, or
129 over 4, if you prefer.
OK, so that's going to
be our answer there.
So now let's go back
and do it again using
this alternate parametrization.
So in this alternate
parametrization,
we had x equal e to the t,
and y equal e to the 2t.
So in that case, that means
that dx-- so x is e to the t,
y is e to the 2t, so our
integral that we want,
let me rewrite it.
Well, actually, let
me not rewrite it.
Let me just go back here
and take a look at it.
So we want the
integral of F dot dr,
and we know that that's equal
to the integral over C of x*y dx
plus x squared
plus y squared dy.
So x is e to the t,
y is e to the 2t,
so that means dx is
going to be e to the t dt
and dy is going to
be 2 e to the 2t dt.
So OK.
So we'll just have to
plug these things in.
So our integral-- maybe I'll
give it a name: What We Want.
WWW.
What We Want is equal
to the integral of,
well we start plugging in.
So x*y dx is e to the t
times e to the 2t times,
we said dx is e to the t dt.
Plus, now x squared
plus y squared,
so that's e to the 2t--
that's x squared-- plus e
to the 4t-- that's y squared--
times 2 d to the 2t dt.
That's dy.
Whew.
OK.
But this integral is
missing something, right?
Because it needs to be
a definite integral.
Right now, I've written
down an indefinite integral.
So that's a problem.
So we need to think, what
are the bounds on this curve?
What are we integrating
from and to?
So let's go all the way back and
look at the problem over here.
So this is the
parametrization of the curve,
and we need it to connect
the points (1, 1) and (2, 4).
So we need to know
which value of t
puts this parametrization
at the point (1, 1),
and which value of t puts
it at the point (2, 4).
Well, I think the easiest way
to do that is to solve this,
and we have t equals
natural log of x.
So natural log of 1 is
0, and natural log of 2
is natural log of 2.
So OK.
So we want t to go from
0 to natural log of 2.
To go from this
point to that one.
OK, so 0 to natural log of 2.
Let's remember that, and come
back over here and put that in.
So we want this
integral that we're
trying to compute using this
alternate parametrization--
we've already written down what
the integrand is-- but it's
going to be the
integral, we just said,
from 0 to the natural log of 2.
OK.
Great.
So now let's take this integral
and let's start simplifying it.
So let's see.
This is an e to the t times
e to the 2t times e to the t,
so that's e to the 4t dt.
And here we have-- that looks
like a 2 e to the 4t plus 2 e
to the 6t dt.
So if we combine like terms,
we get the integral from 0
to natural log of 2.
So we had an e to
the 4t and a 2 e
to the 4t, so that's 3 e to
the 4t plus 2 e to the 6t dt.
OK, 3 e to the 4t
plus 2 e to the 6t.
OK.
And this is also a
different-looking integral
than the one we had before,
but it's not a difficult one
to evaluate, because it's just
e to a constant times t dt.
Pretty straightforward
stuff, I think.
So what does it
actually give us?
Let me come up here
and write it up here.
So this is equal to-- all
right, integrate e to the 4t,
and you get e to the 4t over
4, so this is 3/4 e to the 4t,
plus 2/6-- so that's
plus 1/3 e to the 6t,
and we're evaluating
that between 0 and ln 2.
And I will leave it
to you to confirm
that what you get
when you do this
is you get exactly 129 over 4
when you plug in these values
and take the difference.
So one thing to notice
here is that doing it
with the second parametrization,
we got 129 over 4.
Now, if you look
back just right here,
you see that when we did it
with the first parametrization,
we also got 129 over 4.
Now this is a general
phenomenon, right?
The parametrization
doesn't change
the value of the line integral.
So when you have a line
integral of a vector field,
you can parametrize the curve
that you're integrating over
in a bunch of different ways.
I mean, in fact, infinitely
many different ways.
There are all sorts
of different choices,
and they all give
the same answer.
They have to.
So no matter what
parametrization you choose,
you get the same number
out for the line integral
over the same curve of
the same vector field.
All right.
So what that means
for you is that when
you're given just a
curve and a vector field
and you get to choose
your parametrization,
you should always just choose
whatever the nicest one is.
Because it doesn't
matter which one
you choose, and
there's no reason
ever to choose anything
harder than necessary.
All right.
So now, I want to quickly
recap what we did.
So we had a curve
and a vector field F,
and we were asked to compute
the line integral of F dot dr
and we did it two
different ways.
So in both cases,
we used the fact
that F dot dr is M dx plus N dy.
We wrote that out using the
known values of M and N,
and using the known
components of F.
And then we plugged
in for both cases.
In this case, we used that
first parametrization.
And then over to
my left, we used
this second parametrization
that I gave you.
And in both cases, that
reduced it to an integral
in terms of a single variable t
that was the parameter that we
could compute.
And the answer came out the
same both times, as it had to.
So one thing you
can notice is if you
compare this with the
preceding lecture video,
you'll see that this curve
and vector field, they
connect the same points and
it's the same vector field,
and these answers
both differ from both
of the answers in the
preceding recitation video.
So this is further illustration
that different curves can
give you different values, but
if you take the same curve,
different
parametrizations always
have to give you same values
for that line integral
of the same vector field.
I'll end there.